hello everyone and welcome
hope you had a good lunch good seeing
you all again
it's been a while since I've been in uh
Oslo
I was at the last NDC Oslo as well did
any of you see me last time I was over
here yes
no
okay maybe some of you don't remember
that that hurts
I I didn't think I was so forgettable
uh my name is urita Han by the way I'm
at URI Dahan on all of the socials
twitters Etc uh and we're going to be
talking today about this thing called
cqrs command query responsibilities
segregation
pitfalls and patterns related to that so
just to get a sense of where all you are
at who's heard of cqrs before yes okay
who is it the first time that they're
hearing about cqrs essentially being
dragged here by somebody else saying you
need to hear about this
Okay so
good news is most of you have already
passed the fall which is not knowing
about cqrs
so as two very smart fellows uh Sherlock
Holmes and Doctor Who have mentioned uh
when they don't know a thing they don't
like not knowing about a thing
so for all those of you who don't like
not knowing about cqrs you've come to
the right place now the second Pitfall
is overusing cqrs
so whether it's vitamins or antibiotics
or any kind of good thing in life there
is sort of an appropriate level of use
and then there's overuse where it
becomes toxic and bad for us
now I know we've just kind of launched
immediately into here's a pitfall here's
another Pitfall let's take a step back
and ask the question of what would you
say
cqrs is anyway because it's one of those
acronyms in software or terms you know
micro Services is another one that you
know there's a whole lot of definitions
and sort of different flavors of the
thing out there and that actually causes
a lot of difficulty
um so uh who is at Sam Newman's talk
about the asynchrony one yeah okay a
bunch of you have he kind of made that
emphasis saying you know it's important
for us to have a shared language and
agreed upon terms and meanings to things
so that ultimately we can talk and
collaborate with each other so that when
I say cqrs and you hear cqrs we both
know we're talking about the same thing
now
just to frame it in terms of well you
know other things that already exist in
our industry what is Securus the best
way to characterize it compared to other
things is that cqrs is an architectural
style
now for some of you you're like oh yes
of course obviously and some of you are
saying oh architectural style that's the
first I've heard of architectural Styles
would you do me a favor and explain to
me what an architectural style is
so
the thing about our industry is we use
the term architecture a lot we might do
object oriented architecture layered
architecture service oriented
architecture we kind of use that end
term architecture
after other things so again service
oriented event-driven architecture all
of those things are not actually
architectures they are architectural
Styles and the best way to think of them
is it's just a way of organizing things
in software so we've got the towels
which are nice and neatly layered one on
top of the other however when it comes
to detergent detergent is not the kind
of thing that you would try to layer one
on top of the other a jar would probably
be a better way of organizing that thing
and you got baskets and buckets and
whatever so
architectural Styles ways of organizing
things cqrs as an architectural style
Seekers is a way of organizing some
things in software so you've mentioned
already a bunch of other architectural
Styles you might have been familiar with
model view controller and VC also a way
of organizing things it's a kind of
architectural style rest also is another
one representational state transfer a
way of organizing these things
now the important thing about all of
these architectural styles to remember
is
they are not best practices
that's important enough I'm going to say
that again because we oh my god do we
love best practices
as an industry we've got so many best
practices
it's surprising we don't have any pretty
good practices
or not very good practices we've got
empty patterns yeah we know those right
got plenty of anti-patterns right the
bad stuff don't do that
then this Chasm of nothingness and then
over here we've got a pile of best
practices
right
when you think about most things in life
that there isn't that really strong
dichotomy between the best and the
absolute worst
so when we're talking about
architectural styles again whether it's
layering whether it's MVC whether it's
event driven architecture or cqrs none
of them are best practices unto
themselves they're tools use them when
and where they are appropriate
and that's where we sort of get into it
say for a given system of any kind of
scalar and complexity you're probably
going to use a bunch of them and that's
what makes it tricky because we want the
best practice oh layered architecture is
the best practice okay everything's
going into layers
simple straightforward just layer all of
the things and you know project will be
a success
that didn't work well layering Now sucks
it's in the worst practices bucket
what's the next thing event driven
architecture yes eventually everything
will be an event
and then we event all of the things and
we Event Source and we event drive and
we event Orient and then we run into
problems with too many events and event
schema changes and then we say that
event thing that's crap nope throw it
back over there
please don't do that all right
you got screwdrivers you got hammers you
got saws we use all of these tools for
various different things same thing when
it comes to architectural Styles so
let's go into secure us what do we even
mean about it now that we can say okay
it's an architectural style we have an
idea what other things are out there are
that are architectural styles that it
relates to
where does it come from well before we
had cqrs we had this thing called
command query separation
all right now this was coined by a very
smart fellow Bertrand Meyer back in 1994
when he wrote a book and he described it
as a programming principle that states
that every method on a given class
should either be a command which is
performing some kind of action or
alternatively a query which is returning
data to the caller but most importantly
not both
so there should never be a situation
where you're querying something and then
that changes its state
so hopefully most of you when you're
programming don't do that
like I said this is 1994 close to 30
years ago at the programming level we've
come a fairly long way in terms of the
programming practices but
when we start looking at them sort of
from an architectural perspective that's
where applying those things gets a
little bit tricky now another challenge
we have as an industry and it's really
unfortunate is that things that are old
we kind of forget them rather quickly we
like the new stuff oh yes absolutely
rust yes totally let's rewrite
everything in Rust it will be faster
that way we're sure right
but the ideas of 30 years ago 40 years
ago from software though those aren't
new and shiny don't get accepted to
speak at a conference about old type of
topics
so that's where we started saying
command query separation it's a good
idea at the programming level
and then you know about a decade went by
we totally forgot about command query
separation these books then came along
patterns of Enterprise application
architecture domain driven design
uh just a quick show of hands who's read
these books before yes
okay
um I'm going to be a little bit
difficult with you who read them all the
way through
okay I'm seeing a few more hands kind of
be like uh we're at a half set
right
the the reading it all the way through
it's kind of like yeah there's some good
stuff in there I think I understood some
of it
and then again sort of promptly forget
the rest of it so since those books came
along as an industry we said let's go do
domain models who's got a domain model
in their system
yes all the hands going up of course we
have domain models it's a best practice
so
what do we do with those domain models
well we put all of our logic in them
and then as a result of that those
domain models that started kind of nice
and right sized started to get bigger
and bigger and more complex
and then somewhere along the way it kind
of got really difficult to manage the
complexity of those domain models
now remember I asked you about who read
the book there's actually an interesting
comment about the domain model pattern
in the book I'm going to quote it for
you
so
where should you be using a domain model
and where should you not because as a
pattern not a best practice it has a
context it has a place where it is
supposed to be used and places where
it's not supposed to be used so here is
a literal quote from the book where it
says if you have some simple not null
checks and a couple of sums to calculate
a transaction script is a better bet
in other words domain model was not
actually meant to handle all of the
logic in the system
was meant to handle specifically the
complicated and ever-changing business
rules
now
just so that you can check me and keep
me honest that's on page 119 of patterns
of Enterprise application architecture
so now that we know that domain models
were not meant to be used for everything
and now we realize we kind of were using
them for all of the logic and then that
might have created some problems for us
then maybe we can start thinking of
taking some steps back from there so
that's already one of the pitfalls it's
not directly related to cqrs but in my
experience there's a large amount of
overlap between people doing cqrs and
those using domain models
and a lot of the times it's the domain
models kind of get big and complex and
that causes issues that sometimes people
say oh that's a problem with cqrs
so no actually it started somewhere else
that was at the Domain model level
now the other thing about those domain
models as we made them bigger and bigger
and bigger
we found out that you know using them
for queries
just you know
uncomfortable difficult
as we started spreading things around in
one to many this and many to many that
and we partitioned different entities
into different places it yeah it just
strengthens the fact that oh yeah we
should be treating queries differently
and that's when that idea came to say
you know what domain models are great
you know we like them however
what if we did not use the domain model
for everything
what if we started to split off for
example the queries that you know cqs
thing that we were talking about before
and we didn't have that go through the
domain model
go through something else
and instead of having just one API for
everything which is sort of like you
know the Gateway through which all
clients talk to and that API is using
the one domain model for everything and
that's going and talking to the one
database for everything
what if we split that up and essentially
created two slightly different apis one
of them for commands one of them for
queries they're connected to each other
because ultimately they're dealing with
the same data but they are different
they serve different purposes but they
sort of interlock together in good ways
so essentially at sort of an
architectural diagram level not a big
deal it's kind of like okay we used to
have one API box now we've got two
queries over here commands over there
standard cqrs great right what's not to
like
so
if we just stopped there as an industry
then maybe this talk would be a bit
shorter but like with many things like
you know once you have something of a
good thing you try to uh extend it and
Abstract it and use it for more things
so beyond the standard cqrs approach we
took it one step further and said you
know
it's kind of hard
to do good queries and good commands and
good Logic on either side of those when
both of those are talking to the same
database
because the database kind of serves as a
constraint what's the database designed
for is it designed for the commands is
it designed for the queries how do we
optimize that
so the idea came along and said well
what if we took this command query
separation and not just stop at the API
level but go all the way through to the
database level let's give each API its
own database and then we'll optimize the
query data model for queries to be able
to handle those really quickly and
that's essentially where the whole idea
of no SQL started coming along to say
instead of having to join 17 tables in
order to answer a query what if we
created documents with a little bit of
duplicated data between them but then
our queries would be a lot faster and
simpler and then once we had that out of
the way well we could simplify the
command side as well because we wouldn't
need to have a command database that had
to address all sort of really
complicated queries
so
sounded even better than before of
course we need some kind of mechanism to
keep the command database where we're
updating all of the data constantly to
be in sync with the query database
so uh now I call that to distinguish it
from the cqrs that we were talking about
before calling this eventually
consistent cqrs because we've got the
command API going and talking to its
command database
and then we've got the query API going
and talking to its own query database
and then we need to have some mechanism
and it's usually going to be
asynchronous
there's that word again that Sam Newman
told you about right say asynchronous
meaning sometime after we update the
command database we go and update the
query database and there will be some
kind of component that is responsible
for doing that here I'm just using a
generic query updater type of term so
we're issuing events from our Command
API after we have successfully updated
our Command database and then that gets
reflected up in the query database so uh
as you know double the database double
the fun minions are happy
an even better pattern but now when
we're talking about cqrs for the rest of
this talk I'm going to try to be
specific and talk about standard cqrs
meaning single database cqrs versus
eventually consistent cqrs where we've
got multiple databases all right so
there are two different styles to those
things now at the beginning of this talk
I asked you to raise your hand say who's
doing cqrs now what I want to do is I
want to get a little bit more specific
who's doing the standard one database
style of cqrs can I get some hands yes
okay and who's doing the eventually
consistent two database style of it okay
so it's about a quarter are doing the
eventually consistent style and I've got
three quarters that are doing the
standard style
now
great so far
things start it's important to recognize
that a lot of the patterns that we've
got today we didn't invent them they
they were around before
and there are other ways of doing those
as well
so my guess is that a bunch of you have
heard about this thing called database
replication before
right it's a fairly old technology
pretty much all of the database vendors
out there support it both on-prem and in
the cloud general idea is that there is
some sort of primary node where all of
the rights are going to that primary
node then replicates those changes to
read replicas that essentially have a
copy of the data but those replicas are
there only for query type of terms so
essentially database replication this
idea of primary replica replication
already has a kind of secure us at play
at the database level
so in some cases
even before you start thinking let's go
write a bunch of code maybe look at what
the database has to offer and say maybe
that solves the problem for me already
and I don't have to do any additional
separation over the top just as a quick
note this replication style is
essentially the same data model so it's
not like the eventually consistent style
where not only did we have two different
databases they were actually two
different database schema they were
structured differently from each other
when we're talking about database level
replication it's the same schema
in all of the places but the data is
copied and replicated between them so
it's a variant of what we were talking
about before logically it's standard
cqrs territory from a physical
deployment perspective it's a lot more
like the eventually consistent cqrs
model all right
so that's another style pretty much all
of the database have have this and it
solves a lot of scalability issues it
you know never ceases to amaze me
essentially since
orms took over the world that developers
really stopped learning about database
capabilities we treat it almost kind of
like a dumb file system where they're
actually application servers in their
own right and they have lots of
capabilities it's worth getting to know
them other things that they can do
include sharding
sharding is where the data is actually
split apart logically between different
database instances
and then you know it gives you a scaling
out also on your right side as well and
not just on the read side
anyway you know it could be a whole talk
just talking about database
functionality and features and
replication and sharding and those
things it's worth taking some time
reading up on it for whatever database
technology you're using it will serve
you well it's another tool toolbox it's
essentially another kind of cqrs that's
available to you
so
how else does cqrs go wrong uh
essentially by applying it as a best
practice so one of the places the most
common places is in the context of
simple crud when doing create read
update delete and we have some fairly
simple straightforward data a couple of
strings a couple of IDs maybe a date or
something like that and you just need to
get that from the UI into database and
back out again all right so create read
update delete I mean you could do like
the standard cqrs type of thing and put
the query off on the one side and then
the commands on the other side but it's
kind of unnecessary but sometimes people
because they're like well we're using
cqrs for everything else we'll also use
it for the simple stuff so it's not
terrible but it sort of compounds up and
makes things just more complex over time
you know every once in a while we
complain about having big balls of mud
but you know every single time we take
something simple and make it more
complex we don't realize that's how the
big ball of mud came into being it's
just you know one extra line of code at
a time
so if you have this type of relatively
simple straightforward crud type of
solution there's this great technology
out there you might have heard about it
called Ruby on Rails two-tier
active record style there's no actual
domain model over there rails was
created to be the fastest most developer
friendly way to do forms over data so
for those of you that are purely on the
Microsoft platform think Ms access
all right Microsoft Access was a great
database very simple fast way to go and
build a UI that had data be persisted
and shown back again if that's all that
you need then absolutely use that
now
when you get into sort of the crud
territory and for those of you that are
saying we're not going to do standard
cqrs we're going to do eventually
consistent cqrs that's where things
actually start going quite badly
the problem being that as a user when I
go insert a record into a database
I expect when I click to the query
screen that that record will be there
right it's kind of an obvious
expectation when you say it that way
right however because the query updater
might be working asynchronously the data
might not appear
in the query database just then and then
the user looks as you know it's kind of
pressing F5 F5 my data is not there
what does the user do in that case
they go and insert the data again
do you think the system lost it
then they type it in again and then they
click submit
and then they go back to the query
screen press refresh and like oh yes now
it's there everything's great
five minutes later 10 minutes later
they're doing some other work they come
back to the query screen what do they
see
two entries right
same stupid system
how did it duplicate my data why did it
duplicate my data of course the user
duplicated the data
but we as Engineers created an
environment where users would do that
and then that starts to create data
quality issues of saying well now you've
got two IDs
that might the user might be connecting
different things to those different
identifiers
and then just sort of bad things start
to accumulate
you know kind of goes from bad to worse
towards the longer those duplicates
stick around there
so I don't want to say that eventual
consistency eventually consistent cqrs
is all bad but in the context of single
user type of crud
that is where there's a lot of these
types of issues we don't tend to catch
them when we're building and debugging
the system right because when we're
working on it we're you know pressing F5
debugging everything is running live we
type something in the system has zero
load there is no lag between the right
side and the read side so we always see
that the queries are fresh
but when the system is under the most
load that's when becomes the most
delayed and that's when the users really
don't like it so in your case imagine
when you're a user you go add something
to your shopping basket in Amazon and
you're like oh okay great let's go check
out and then you go to checkout and on
the checkout screen your basket is empty
it's kind of like that that's not
supposed to happen that way
now again these types of problems only
manifest once the system is under load
so again the the whole eventually
consistent cqrs has its place but be
aware of the fact that Dynamic of what
it's going to look like with the single
user reading their own rights
now
this leads us to our next pattern or our
next context for cqrs and that's the
difference between private data and
public data
now
most of the time as developers we just
look at data as data we got data in a
database and users you know save it
update it you know connect it to other
things
but we don't always think of it enough
sort of from the business perspective
and it's helpful to to use this Framing
and also to understand how users think
about the data in the system a lot of
times especially some of the older users
we've been trained to save data so that
it doesn't get lost
right some of us we kind of already have
that control s habit you know doing some
work control s doing some more work
control less why
just in case
right because we've had a problem we've
lost hours and hours of work so when we
save data the context is I don't want to
lose this
the context is not please tell everybody
about this change that I made right now
right now the way that we often Design
Systems there is no difference once the
user clicks save
it's in the database table other users
who query that table can now see that
data and they can start doing stuff with
it
so as a first step in terms of applying
this idea of private versus public data
try to introduce that distinguishing
characteristic already in the UI think
of your system as having like a Content
management system element to it
so for those of you that have blogged or
that you know Facebook or Twitter or
whatever we've got a publish step where
it's explicitly published this to the
whole internet
versus save as draft so for those using
GitHub as well there's save as a draft
right you got your own little workspace
we're used to having that now as users
when we Design Systems that's also
something that we should be introducing
for them so we've got the private data
you can save that think of that as
saving that as a draft and then at some
point the user can click the publish
button
and then we'll say are you sure this is
going to make the data public and all
the other users can use it it will
appear on the such and such page the
user says okay great now the data goes
into the public domain essentially we
can look at cqrs command query
responsibility segregation and apply
that same kind of idea to private versus
public data that we've got a private
data type of API that is appropriate for
crud type of work that could be very
simple straightforward Ruby on Rails
type of thing that is talking to a
database versus the public API which is
showing data that has already been
designated to be public essentially
inside of our database we've got some
flag that is the is public
flag to indicate should this be made
public to other people or not
so essentially it looks pretty much the
same as standard cqrs it's just has a
different semantic instead of dividing
commands versus queries we're dividing
private data versus public data now we
can take the whole cqrs thing the
eventually consistent style and also
apply that in the context of private and
public data where we could say there is
private data and we're going to put that
in the private data database because
we're kind of afraid that some developer
will make some mistake not set the flag
or the flag will get changed by accident
so we create some deeper separation
between the private data and the public
data and then when the user clicks the
explicit I would like to publish this
then we publish an event and we carry
that data over explicitly to the public
data database
so essentially it looks pretty much just
like the eventually consistent cqrs
Story the difference is really more the
semantics what we're using it for
now
when doing this
this gives us a whole bunch of benefits
on the user side
it solves the problem of essentially
using cqrs where we don't need it so in
the case of private data where again
we're just doing Simple crud we don't
need additional cqrs there and on the
public side well we're going to get more
into what how to actually design the
public side because there's a lot more
tricky things down in there but before I
do that I want to come back to one of
the problems of the eventually
consistent cqrs style so for those of
you that aren't using that that's fine
just be aware kind of smile to yourself
with your precious of knowing not to use
this style for those of you that are
using it hopefully this will make you
aware of it and able to solve those
problems so one of the advantages that
we mentioned before of the eventually
consistent cqrs style is that we can
have optimized data models the right
side is optimized for doing rights very
quickly the query side is optimized for
doing queries very quickly and then
we've got this query updater that is
keeping them in sync where's the problem
well it only hits when your system is
under very high load
so when your system is under average
load that query updater component is
able to keep up it's getting these
events saying this changed I'm going to
go update the query database I get
another event I'm going to go update the
query database
now remember that the rate at which this
needs to happen is essentially the rate
at which commands are coming into the
command side
so if you've got a thousand commands a
second that means that we need to be
processing a thousand events per second
in our query updater component now
remember the command side is optimized
for processing commands quickly it's
optimized for doing those updates so it
can do that a thousand times a second
two thousand times a second
the query database was never optimized
for updating
we designed it so it'd be really good to
read from it knowing that we're making a
trade-off that it will be harder to
update it essentially it requires more
processing power to update the query
side then the command side but we need
to update it at the same rate on average
it can sort of peak in flow and whatever
but
if the rate starts to get too high then
the query side can start falling farther
and farther and farther behind
and that's where we usually get into
trouble users start looking at the
system and saying well I'm looking at
the query screen but it's showing me
data from 20 minutes ago
it essentially becomes unusable
and this is a common problem with
systems and also for us as developers is
that we Design Systems we use patterns
in order to make them scale but when
they are under scale they start failing
in these sorts of weird ways
and then we're not exactly sure what to
do and that's usually the worst time so
we'll talk more about that uh in a
little bit but I just want to connect
the dots with some other talk that you
might have seen Jeremy Miller gave the
talk about the vertical slice
architecture who saw Jeremy's talk yes
vertical slice architecture oh not that
many of you more of you should vertical
slice architecture if you haven't heard
about it read about it please go take a
look at it essentially it's you know
this cqrs thing or the private public
responsibility segregation is a kind of
vertical slice architecture where you've
got a certain slice that goes from top
to bottom you can think of it oh that's
kind of layered or that's kind of
layered over there oh we even have a
little bit event driven architecture
down the middle of that so we can have a
bit of both in those things but you know
that's the vertical slice architecture
if you haven't seen it go look into it
we'll touch on it also a little bit more
later let's delve deeper into the public
side of things once the data is public
how do we handle it so the important
thing to realize is once that data is
public multiple users can start using
and operating on that data in parallel
which is why as we mentioned before it's
important to make That explicit so that
users know now it's public and lots of
other things can happen now in some
cases there are some systems that are
designed with this intentionally so it's
like okay we're going to build a
collaborative type of experience this
could be a mirror board if you're
familiar with that or Google Docs or all
those types of places where it's
designed inherently around collaboration
and that's great when there are those
kinds of systems but the more common
case around public data is that it's
kind of more of an accidental bumping
into each other oops sorry I didn't
realize you were working on that data
while I was working on it now sometimes
like for those of you I don't know if
you've used Dropbox or some other type
of collaboration technique then it'll
put up this little badge say oh there's
another user that's working on this
document as the same time as you are
when we're talking about our systems if
there are other users that are fiddling
with data it's more rare that we
actually make that visible to our users
so users don't even realize when they're
stepping on each other's toes now
this is probably sounding a little bit
of abstract so let's start making this a
little bit clearer and more down to
earth so here's how it plays out we got
one user looking at a piece of data
other user for whatever reason goes and
looks at the same data at the same time
none of the users realize that any of
this is happening one of them goes and
changes the data that they're looking at
it succeeds the other user comes along
and goes to change the data as well the
thing is that the data that they're
looking at on their screen before they
make the change is essentially stale
right they don't know what actually
happened that was done by the other user
now some of you might have put in some
you know Azure web Pub sub signalr thing
such that anytime any change happens all
of the users that are looking at it have
it updated automatically and that's lots
of fun to build those types of things
until you're a user and then you're on a
screen and it's a oh this data has
changed you're like okay
refresh and it's like yeah okay that's
irrelevant to the thing that I'm trying
to do so you're going to continue to do
some more work and you get another
notification up data's changed again
and at some point you just start to
disregard it and then you go make the
changes anyway and then again you're
stepping on other people's toes now in
the technical terminology we call this
stepping on each other's toes race
conditions
for those people who are race car
drivers when they step on each other's
toes it can really be quite tragic
this is not just a race condition this
is the car flies into the air and bursts
into a thousand pieces and we hope that
the driver is okay so technically when
we're talking about race conditions
users stepping on each other toes think
about the data in your database
flying up and fragmenting into a
thousand little pieces okay you should
be worried at that level of worry about
race conditions when you're talking
about public data because it's public
because there are lots of users that
could be operating on it at the same
time
now most developers blissfully ignorant
of this right it's a I just write the
code unit test pass I check it in next
day I come to the morning stand up so I
finished my ticket all done today I'm
working on another ticket
you aren't going to need it right none
of that big architecture up front we're
agile here delivering features to the
client the way that they like it
you know I'm not going to have an agile
talk but I gotta tell there there's a
certain amount of uh willful ignorance
on these other concerns that well you
know we don't have a ticket for it
management doesn't allow us to work on
things that don't exist in the ticket
repository so you know it's not our
fault
anyway let's go take a concrete example
of how this happens how this plays out
in a very simple small set of public
data
inventory
so let's say we have you know the
e-commerce type of domain that's been
done to death I know I'm sorry where
we've got some new products that's come
out the next Harry Potter book and of
course all of the Harry Potter people
are just kind of losing their minds oh
my God I got to buy this thing right
away right now the developers that
designed this said right we're going to
have an inventory table I'm including
the name here just for context we don't
actually need the name of the book in
there and we've got a row for every
single item with a quantity column in
there that says how many of that book do
we have in our warehouse simple right
and when a user goes and buys a book
what do we do well we need to go and
update the inventory table how do we do
that well even before we get into object
relational mappers or any of that fancy
stuff
we've got SQL
so ultimately what ends up going to the
database orm or not is SQL a kind of
transaction where first step is well we
kind of need to see how much quantity of
the thing is currently in the database
so we do a select
from the inventory table for that
product ID
and then I said oh okay there's a
thousand items for that ID we go and
then check that there is actually
sufficient quantity in there could be
that this person ordered wanted to order
ten thousand Harry Potter books don't
know why I wanted to wallpaper their
house with Harry Potter type of books so
they check do we check in our
transaction to see that we've got enough
and if we do which we probably should
then we go and update the inventory
table setting the quantity to be the a
minus B right what we had before minus
what the person ordered for that product
ID and then we commit the transaction
very simple two-step process query and
then update at the database level no
eventual consistency right this is in
the database think that I've got a
stored procedure even all right just to
keep things simple
now
works fine great ship it move on what
happens when multiple people
go and order the same book at the same
time and this tends to happen when
there's a very popular new book that
comes out all right so let's say you
know we got about 200 of you over here
all right all 200 of you are going to my
database on a database and issuing
that SQL statement that set of SQL
statements now as a database
I'm really smart I try to paralyze
things so all 200 of you come to me and
say
Udi what's the quantity of the Harry
Potter book and I respond to all of you
saying a thousand
and you're like awesome great I'd like
to buy one book
please update the inventory table set
the quantity of the Harry Potter book to
999.
so I get that command from you and I
update the record to say 999 and I get
the next statement from you and I update
it too
999.
because the queries happen at the same
time the commands are now coming in at
the same time
and every single one of you issues
exactly the same update Command right so
I got 200 people that are buying books a
thousand as the original value and after
all 200 SQL statements have completed
the end result is I've got 999 items in
my inventory table However unfortunately
the folks in the warehouse are kind of
looking around saying uh no it's not
that that many
it's uh we we actually ran out of
inventory you thought you had a thousand
but that was because the last time 200
people came along you only decremented
it by one
and then the time before that that 500
people came along and bought Harry
Potter you also decremented if I want
we're all out
now of course you won't find out about
this in testing because it's rare that
we actually try to do this parallelized
testing to validate correctness
now why does this happen it's this thing
called optimistic concurrency that
databases do by default unless you tell
them not to so essentially databases say
I'm going to try to be you know a good
uh member of your architecture and not
block all of the transactions because
you know some of you might be buying
Harry Potter book one some of you might
be buying you know 50 Shades of Gray
somebody else is buying patterns of
Enterprise application architecture for
some reason
so we don't want to block all of those
transactions those can and should run in
parallel but at the level of a single
record that's where we don't actually
want the optimistic concurrency so even
though optimism is a great personal
quality you know it's nice to have
optimistic people around us in life
optimistic concurrency not such a great
choice for public data especially not
popular public data so again you know
whether it's your marketing department
is running some campaign and saying hey
everybody we've discounted a very
popular item by 50 come and buy it or
you know you know somehow we got
featured on Oprah and now all of the
world is going and buying our stuff
so be aware of this type of thing
optimistic concurrency can actually end
up creating an eventual inconsistency
for your system now as developers we're
like hey no big deal just switch it add
some locking
no problem right
optimistic concurrency bad fine we'll do
best domestic concurrency
so
what happens when we've got pessimistic
concurrency well for the most part under
regular conditions it's you know the
data is now more correct
however on Black Friday the busiest day
of the year where we make 80 percent of
our profit
this is what happens
and the stories you know just happen
almost every year every Black Friday
some major retailer has a major outage
of their site and you hear it on the
news say oh they're trying to get the
site back up
as technical people are like you do
realize it's pushing a button
right you don't actually need to go to
the data center and pick up a rack of
metal to get it back online right what's
so hard about getting this thing back
online well part of it has to do with
the technical dynamics of what happens
at a database level when you introduce
the pessimistic concurrency the culprit
is this thing called The Connection pool
the connection pool dries up
why does that happen well so we've got
this inventory table and we've got all
of you users that are coming along and
wanting to buy books each of you opens
up a connection to the database and I'm
like hello welcome yes
here's a connection here's a connection
here's a connection everybody gets a
connection under the premise that you
all will be very good citizens and
complete your transactions quickly
but what happens when all of you want to
go and buy Harry Potter well you come in
and you go buy a Harry Potter first I'm
like oh okay yes welcome come in I'm
going to lock that record for you at the
same time you're like I'd like to buy
Harry Potter I'm like oh no sorry
pessimistic concurrency please wait
while you're waiting to say hey how can
I what can I do for you like I want
Harry Potter I'm like oh what's up get
in line after him please wait what about
you hey Harry Potter back the line
please wait
and I go through all of you
and what's happening
essentially the connections are left
open
but they're not doing anything
right the queue is building up and
essentially I'm processing them one at a
time
now things get really bad when I ask you
and I say what would you like and say
I'd like patterns of Enterprise
application architecture but it's like
oh wonderful thank God
said okay I'm going to lock that record
and end Harry Potter God damn it
well your transaction can't complete now
you're gonna have to wait
what would you like domain driven design
oh yes God thank you wonderful yes okay
lock that one for you and Harry Potter
okay another transaction that's waiting
but now patterns of Enterprise
application architecture is now locked
waiting on the Queue of Harry Potter
and domain driven design is locked
waiting on the queue for Harry Potter
and all the other users that wanted to
do something eventually they come to the
day say hi database can I have a
connection I'm like
I'm I'm flat out
just you know all these people they're
just here for Harry Potter I can't get
rid of them fast enough
and essentially
at that point saying the site is down
that means the site is unable to get
connections to the database and the
reason is we've got all of these locks
in there that are piling up holding up
the transactions
so
a when designing a system you really
should test for these scenarios like
when these problems occur this is like
the worst case scenario all hands on
deck please you know technical people
somehow please fix this
and there isn't anything
it's like we can't
substantially change the code and the
data model in the middle of Black Friday
so it's like oh I don't try to put the
database on a bigger server it's like oh
okay great now instead of supporting a
thousand concurrent connections we have
5 000 concurrent connections which now
means we can have five times as many
people waiting for Harry Potter as we
did before while everybody else
continues to be blocked
now
really the only solution for these
things is essentially to change the
business model coming to the business up
front saying we're going to need to make
this more flexible have this work
differently because technically we can't
get out of this problem it's you know
we've designed ourselves into a corner
and the only way out is essentially
going all the way back to where we
started now what this means in the
inventory domain is that we need to be
able to accept a temporary negative
inventory type of situation we need to
be able to allow the inventory to go
negative and then have some kind of
logic that asynchronously saying oh
turns out we can't fulfill your order
we'll send you an email about that
afterwards say oh sorry are bad if you
want you can cancel your order but then
we start the back ordering process we
contact our supplier and we get them to
fulfill that thing and then there's some
delays real world delays but the
business flexes and handles it and
everything's okay now that's great for
some domains in others when we say you
know let's go in to do this negative
inventory when it comes to Taylor Swift
tickets you know there just aren't it's
like when they're out they're out and
this recently happened to Ticketmaster
where again you know Taylor Swift comes
along big event everybody wants tickets
there's no getting more tickets when
they're out right that's it that's the
limited inventory and essentially what
happened is Ticketmaster crashed and
kept crashing over and over again and
then they had Congressional hearings in
the U.S as to why people couldn't get
Taylor Swift tickets
kind of thing like of all of the things
government should deal with on the list
of priorities we've got poverty we've
got education we've got crime we've got
climate change what do we hold
Congressional hearings about
Taylor Swift tickets
we know where our priorities lie
so how do we make this thing you know
more flexible well as a general
principle or approach already at the
business level we need to be thinking of
how do we make the business process as a
whole non-blocking it's not just a
technical change it's a whole you know
rethinking of the business process so
again from Sam Newman's talk the whole
asynchronous type of thing what we're
looking for is non-blocking not
necessarily asynchronous where again the
idea of non-blocking say how do we make
this as smooth as possible change the UI
change the business logic so that there
aren't those choke points that stop the
user from succeeding in what it is that
they want to do
one way of potentially doing this is
instead of using like the e-commerce
style of handling it we could charge the
customers up front
don't even let them select their tickets
or where they're sitting first first
thing oh you want Taylor Swift tickets
give me your credit card
anybody who says no that's okay there
are plenty others
right and they'll pay anything
so I know I've got whatever it is 50 000
tailors with tickets
give me the credit card I'll charge you
however much I decide right I'll tell
you and then I'll have the system assign
you a seat automatically
now some of you might be saying I want
to select my own seat I'm like good for
you
I don't care
I'm gonna sell out the concert one way
or another this is the non-blocking most
technically efficient way for me to
process fifty thousand screaming Taylor
Swift fans I do not want 50 000
screaming Taylor Swift fans locked in my
database taking it down right I want
them in and through and out as quickly
as possible
coincidentally this is how the London
Olympics did it when people wanted
tickets for the London Olympics there
wasn't this wait a minute where you know
how do I select my seed it's like just
be happy you got a ticket
it's a different domain it's not the
same as e-commerce inventory
and there were no complaints and again
this was 2012. this was a decade ago
and it worked
and since then the people that worked on
it like yeah you know that's how you do
it
and then everybody else is like oh no
but we want to do with grpc and nosql
database like you're asking the wrong
questions
this is a business question this is a UI
business rules type of flow type of
scenario
now there's another scenario that's
going on that tends to happen behind the
scenes some businesses are aware of it
and they try to ignore it some of them
embrace it
essentially when there's limited
inventory and you can't get any more
essentially what's going to happen is an
auction
tickets are going to go to the highest
bidder
so what tends to happen with the most
popular concerts on Ticketmaster is the
Bots come in buy up as much inventory as
they can as quickly as they can and then
they turn around and they hold auctions
to sell those tickets to the highest
bidder
and of course Ticketmaster and Taylor
Swift are very upset about that
which is a problem which is why we had
Congressional hearings
but essentially it's recognizing the
fact saying if this is going to happen
if this is the nature of the domain
then embrace it model it integrate it
into your system
and you don't necessarily have to pick
you can have different vertical slices
for your private data for when things
are being set up by back office staff
then we've got you know certain
different vertical slice for the back
ordered inventory type of domain where
we can get more inventory when it runs
out we could have the public pre-charge
type of model for another set of data or
the public auction style we don't
necessarily need to have a single
business model a single domain model for
everything that we do we could take
things a step further and do Advanced
composition in the UI that's essentially
stitching data from multiple verticals
together where you know the say the
image of the product and the name of the
product and the kind of things which are
not changing in Fairly static type of
data we put that into one database
inside one vertical slice and other
things related to like the ratings
they're going from another vertical
slice and the the price is coming from
another vertical slice and the inventory
is coming from another vertical slice
and essentially we stitch all of these
things together on the UI together if
you want to see a technique of how to do
this there's that URL for you and it's a
ticket to GitHub repository you'll be
able to see this kind of style of doing
a composite UI it won't be as visually
appealing as this Amazon type of thing
but it will give you an idea of how to
do these more advanced composition
techniques
now I know some of you are going to say
right but why is it that I need to
create like all of these different uis
and business logic types of Things
Different databases can't we have some
generic platform that does all of those
things in sort of a standard way
because you know our business
stakeholders they don't like answering
these questions they're like
we hired you to fix these problems for
us so fix it make the system scale you
know solve all of those problems now you
can try you know I've seen so many
companies try but it it just doesn't
scale
every single time the problem being it's
not the hardware when people say you
know how do we make it scale oh we'll
throw more Hardware at it you know you
can't do that with the database so much
you can scale up a database it's really
expensive to do so but then you just
sort of buy yourself a little bit more
time you're like okay so yeah we got a
10 million dollar database server in
order to be able to support a hundred
thousand concurrent connections to the
database maybe that'll hold us till next
Wednesday
beyond that it's kind of like well what
are we going to do when the next big
thing comes along it's like um
find another company
we're developers right we're not stuck
we can go anywhere we want
anyway I know I've tossed a lot of stuff
at you a lot of pitfalls a lot of
patterns
um you know luckily this talk is being
recorded it'll be available online uh
you can follow up afterwards and if you
want to go into more in depth uh I'll be
down at the particular software Booth
come chat with me talk about your cqrs
questions and concerns I'll be happy to
address them and for those of you that
um you know prefer to kind of continue
on on your own time there's a free cqrs
course that I've got online it's
available at this link
go.particular.net
ndc-oslo
23-odi so hopefully those resources will
give you a lot to continue on uh it was
so wonderful being here and talking to
you all about cqrs my name is
online thank you so much have a great
rest of your conference
[Applause]